hi there i wanted to do a video as well
on the situation in the ukraine because
it's so tremendously important uh it's a
strategically important place uh
it's a country that has nuclear weapons
i think
um and uh
you know i i didn't have a very good
understanding of what was going on there
uh which meant that i had clearer
opinions now that i've learned a bit
more my opinions are not quite so clear
uh the one thing i hope is that the the
outsiders the russians the european
union the us
don't cause trouble
uh because it's clear to me that the uh
main forces behind the uh
the anti-government demonstrations and
those people
that they're not so interested in russia
or the european union or
the united states those are not their
primary concerns
it seems to me to be very much a
nationalistic almost like an uprising
and uh
from uh and of course
listening to uh russian sources like
echo muskegon and reading a variety of
sources on the internet
i get a perspective that's different
from what i get out of a simplified
article in my local newspaper
but
it seems to me and i you know i could be
totally wrong on this this is based on a
few hours of
listening and investigating
that
the leading forces of the sort of
demonstrators that the best organized
the most powerful
are
this
right
sector which is a very nationalistic
militantly nationalistic organization
and the svoboda or freedom party which
is also very nationalistic and in
addition to being nationalistic appears
to be quite xenophobic
uh
and these are the ones that are best
organized very often in any kind of a
revolutionary situation it'll be the
best organized who come to the fore and
everyone else kind of just tags along
and doesn't have very much power
uh
and so
you know the danger here is you know and
and so their their agenda is nationalism
but then what the country is just about
bankrupt
um and of course part of the reason
they're
you know i was going to say too that a
lot of my traditional perceptions of you
know the western ukraine being
nationalist
more ukrainian nationalists the eastern
ukraine being more
closer to russia i'm not sure how true
that is
this um there was an interview or not an
interview there was a discussion on
ekamuskvi of this
dmitry yarosh
who is this enigmatic leader
of the right sector he's from the
eastern ukraine
you know the eastern ukraine
eastern and southern ukraine are the
areas that suffered the most from the
tremendous famines that were essentially
engineered by the soviets in the 30s to
requisition grain and to destroy the
power
of the
more independent peasants and while the
ukrainians suffered disproportionately
areas of russia also suffered but in the
sort of ukrainian
independent or nationalistic uh
mythology ideology it's presented as a
genocide directed primarily at them so
you have all these eastern ukrainians
who feel that they were victimized by
the russians
so i don't know how pro-russian those
people are have no idea
uh the western ukrainians
of course were under
poland
uh until 1939 when that was annexed by
um the soviets under the molotov
ribbon-trop pact but when they were
under the polls the polls were
definitely suppressing ukrainian
nationalism and as a result
after
the
germans marched in
for a brief period the
ukrainian nationalists in the western
ukraine
massacred
tens of thousands of polish
of women and children and men presumably
as well
and we're very xenophobic anti-russian
polish jewish you name it and these
this group
uh is sort of the ideological
uh
you know inspiration for
these nationalist organizations in the
ukraine today
so it's all a little bit
complicated and then you have russia
and my impression from listening to
russians is they don't really want to
recognize
the separate nationalist aspirations of
the ukrainians to them
and if you go back far enough in history
of course kiev is considered the mother
of russian cities and and they kind of
feel well we're all the same we're one
big family uh historically we're
together and then for a variety of
historical reasons separated
so the russians don't have much sympathy
for ukrainian nationalism and see the
ukraine more in terms of its
its position as as part of the
russian kind of geopolitical aspirations
of wanting to reestablish this
um you know group of of countries that
or or that space that was once part of
zara's russia
so all of these things are are
playing into it and of course it's
complicated by the fact that the present
government or the government of
yanukovych i guess he's no longer i
don't know where he is
uh is so corrupt or was so corrupt
he was elected
quite fairly in 2010 but since he's been
in power his son has become one of the
richest people in the ukraine
apparently according to some sources has
50 percent of government contracts and
all of a sudden since his dad's in power
he's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars
and a lot of the oligarchs who supported
yanukovych and was hoping that he would
be their puppet
now we're disenchanted with him
because he's moved a lot of assets over
to his son
and so these people in fact are in favor
of getting closer to the european union
so they could have that economic
you know association and strength and
their position vis-a-vis the government
but i think the average protester on on
the maidan square in
in kiev
seems to be controlled by the
nationalists
uh
this is my interpretation
and i don't really see a solution i i i
i think is going to be a very dicey my
hope is that the russians the europeans
and the americans
don't
start fighting each other or don't start
disagreeing with each other but work
together somehow to encourage
some kind of
peaceful settlement but i have the
impression that's going to be a very
very difficult task
so
that's i i talked about this because i
as i say i got involved in listening to
stuff on echo muskeg
in russian uh which piqued my interest
but also i also had a comment from
someone in russian
on my youtube channel
who made me aware that some of the
forces there that my interpretation of
the situation was a bit simplistic so i
did a bit more research
and i'm going to continue to listen and
i just want to point out as well that
that very often
quote patriotic russians tell me that i
shouldn't listen to echo musk v that
they're
anti-patriotic or anti-russian or
russophobe or all this stuff but
actually there's a variety of stuff
there there are people who are way out
to lunch uh whose opinions that you know
that they don't influence me but there's
a whole range of opinions
um
somewhat anti-government for sure and
and i think the fact that such a radio
station exists
is uh is a demonstration of the fact
that russia is not china there is
actually
freedom of expression uh as long as you
don't get too big or too powerful
there's freedom of expression and which
is a good thing
at any rate i'm used to listening to
them i go there if i found another
russian source of audio and text
material
that had independent opinions presented
a variety of opinions i'd go there too
but i do enjoy echo musky
and that's it and i look forward to your
comments
bye for now